à l'Assemblée générale de l'ONU les
débats ont commencé dans un contexte
tendu un peu plus tôt la Russie a
bombardé plusieurs villes ukrainiennes
dont la capitale qui est
de missiles sur des civils de manchestre
ou se rendant au travail sur des enfants
allant à l'école la Russie encore une
fois prouvée qu'elle était un état
terroriste que l'on doit dissuader de la
plus forte des manières
[Musique]
un argument de plus pour convaincre un
maximum d'État membre de voter la
résolution condamnant l'annexion récente
de quatre régions ukrainiennes par
Moscou un texte à l'initiative de
l'Ukraine et de l'Union européenne et
soutenue par les États-Unis avec un
double objectif
souligner l'illégalité des référendum
lancé par Moscou au regard du droit
international mais aussi démontrer
l'isolement de la Russie
en mars dernier 5 pays dont la Russie
avait voté contre une résolution
exigeant le retrait des forces russes de
l'Ukraine
35 pays dont la Chine c'était alors
abstenu
sept mois plus tard certains soutient à
l'Ukraine semblent séroder notamment en
Afrique et au Proche-Orient face à une
guerre considérée comme européenne en
septembre la Russie avait mis son veto à
un précédent texte condamnant les
annexions en Ukraine 4 pays dont la
Chine est l'Inde c'était abstenus keV et
sperme malgré tout rallié entre 100 et
141 voix pour cette nouvelle résolution
en bref